this is super interesting we've been
talking about
declining interest in vaccination uh
the people who already have been
vaccinated are mostly people who
really wanted to be vaccinated and now
we have a situation where supply is
starting to exceed demand
and governments state governments need
to figure out
new ways to get people interested in
getting vaccinated because remember no
matter what anybody tells you there's no
mandatory
vaccination per governments there are
certain schools that will say if you
want to come to campus you have to go
and get a vaccine
or if you want to work for us you have
to go and get a vaccine
but there are no mandatory vaccinations
per the federal
state or municipal governments but you
have an
interest from governments state
governments they want to be open and
they want to be open in a way where
people aren't going to get sick because
that's what's best for business so
they're thinking of new ways to
encourage people to get vaccinated
republican ohio governor mike dewine
is creating five one million dollar
basically lottery rewards for people who
get vaccinated
five people who get vaccinated in ohio
are going to win a million dollars each
the republican governor announced this
last night
all vaccinated adults will be eligible
to enter a lottery that will pay out one
million dollars
each to five winners starting
just a couple of weeks from today march
20th may 26th rather
and separately dewine is also offering
five
vaccinated teenagers full ride
scholarships
to the state's public universities
including tuition
room board and textbooks the textbooks
are key oftentimes you hear free tuition
right but what about the thousands of
dollars for textbooks
it will even include that uh dewine said
in a statewide address quote i know some
may say dewine you're crazy
the million dollar drawing idea of yours
is a waste of money
but truly the real waste at this point
in the pandemic
when the vaccine is readily available to
anyone who wants it
is a life lost to covid 19.
i think that this is absolutely
fantastic and understand
that you have money
set aside already in a number of
different states
for vaccination and for getting people
vaccinated in public awareness campaigns
this is a way of using five million of
that dollars instead of on
billboards and tv ads or whatever the
case may be you're saying well let's
just give five million plus the cost of
tuition to the five teenagers to some
people
and i think it's absolutely fantastic
the lottery payout will be funded
using federal coronavirus relief money
allocated to the states states and
localities have been given this money by
the treasury they've been given wide
discretion about how to spend it
and mike dewine is saying let's give it
to some people
there are questions as to how effective
public health officials think that this
is going to be
tara smith who teaches epidemiology at
kent state university
says there's some research to suggest
small financial incentives could
increase vaccine rates
but that just giving a million dollars
to five people
uh may not work because the perceived um
odds of winning are relatively low and
that if there is a criticism of it
that was my thought which is a million
dollars for five people
uh that's a lot but what about giving a
hundred
thousand dollars to 50 people it's the
same amount of money
but i think the perceived odds of
winning will be higher and of course
they will be they would be 10 times
higher
let's listen to mike dewine announcing
this and talking about this yesterday
on may 26th we will announce a winner of
a separate drawing for adults
adults who have received at least their
first dose of the vaccine
this announcement will occur each
wednesday for five weeks
and the winner each wednesday will
receive
1 million dollars so i think it's a
great idea
the again the only change i might make
is instead of
five people get a million dollars each
i might make it 50 people get a hundred
thousand dollars
and uh the you know the alternative that
was also proposed is
just pay everyone who gets the vaccine
figure out how many people
how many adults you have um divide up
the five million dollar prize pool what
does it work out to
give that to everybody and then for the
unspoken for money at the end of the
campaign
maybe then that becomes uh some sort of
like a lottery or something like that a
lot of different ways to do this
i think it's a i have no moral problems
with it at all
and if it's effective i'm 100 for it let
me know your thoughts
let me know if you would go about it a
slightly different way
and we'll have more coverage of what
different states are doing to encourage
vaccination
on our instagram page which you can find
at davidpakmanshow
you can also find me on instagram at
david.pakman
one of our sponsors is vincero watches
giving you 15 percent off
a high quality wristwatch is the perfect
way to
elevate your style own at least one
watch
that makes you feel great when you put
it on you can often see me wearing
my vincero watch on the show mine is the
gunmetal
vessel model i'm a big fan of the
metallic look
of the face of the watch i like the
silicone strap
you won't find a better made watch for
this good a price
anywhere else when you put it on you
know you got more than you paid for
vincero believes in crafting super
quality watches from high-end materials
but selling them at fair prices which is
why they have over twenty six thousand
five star reviews and they stand behind
every watch they make with a one-year
return policy
and five-year warranty they'll give you
15
off everything in their store and free
shipping at davidpakman.com
watch use the coupon code pacman